jesse eisenberg plays a pizza delivery
man in this movie and I saw so much
pizza so much pizza is like flashed in
front of your faces I want a pizza so
bad as soon as the movie ended I
literally drove right to the pizza shop
and bought a pizza and eat it on the way
home let me mention les is the same
director as Zombieland that also starred
Jesse Eisenberg as well as this movie as
well as these and sorry Danny McBride
and Nick Swardson as well as Fred from
tremors yeah
tremors best use of the f-word in film
ever it's about these two idiots played
by Danny McBride and Nick Swardson we
decide that they would like some money
and the best way to get some money is to
force someone to rob a bank for them so
they kidnap Jesse Eisenberg strapped a
bomb to his chest and force him to rob a
bank and get the money for them
otherwise they're gonna blow him up
Jesse Eisenberg was good in the film and
I didn't mind Aziz Ansari I thought they
played off each other well and I thought
they had good chemistry they seemed like
they were friends and there were some
funny things to their relationship in
the beginning of the film where they
were arguing about things but this is
one of those movies where the comedy
just flies at you so fast just flies and
right in your face so fast and all these
jokes children's my job and you can't
even follow it sometimes I was sort of
just kind of accepting it and dealing
with it and letting it flow until Danny
McBride's character was introduced and
this movie was ruined for me on such a
humongous level
I saw your highness and I thought Danny
McBride was you know I couldn't tolerate
him I got used to him for some reason in
the movie and I think it's because I had
Natalie Portman to distract me however
in this movie there is no Natalie
Portman everything about the guy knows
me he ruined this movie for me honestly
his character is so stupid and annoying
and it's not just his character because
there is no character it's just Danny
McBride he's playing the exact same
character as in your highness he doesn't
talk in that that old medieval style
language Danny McBride thinks that it's
so hilarious if he just keeps saying
certain words of throwing them into
certain sentences he's not funny I'm
sorry I don't find Danny McBride funny
at all there are good things
the film though I enjoy jesse eisenberg
character and the way Hammond Aziz
bounced out for one another
was good and there were definitely some
flight parts in the film however really
the problem is so many of them were in
the trailer however I did enjoy the
story of Jesse Eisenberg's character and
he was he he portrayed him very well and
he would feel the situation you could
feel how you know like how
nerve-wracking in that situation would
be he was good Nick Swardson was alright
he was okay danny mcbride and them those
two characters that half of the movie
sucked
another thing the characters are so
unrealistic do you really expect me to
believe that Aziz Ansari's character is
a teacher and when Jesse Eisenberg busts
in on him in the middle of class that he
actually ends up agreeing to completely
abandon his class and go help his buddy
rob a bank with hardly any second
thoughts at all do you really expect me
to believe the two idiots standing
mcbride and nick swardson who literally
are portrayed as a bottom of the barrel
idiots you really expect me to accept
that they can build such a complex bomb
to strap the Jesse Eisenberg with timers
and codes No
so I'm gonna have to give him 30 minutes
or less one and a half out of four stars
I can understand how some people would
like it maybe like the really young guys
would like it I walked the schmoes
review they said stones drunk kind of
guys would like it I can see that too so
yeah I'm not really a fan of 30 minutes
or less I had some good parts Eisenberg
was good but for the most part the film
does really annoys me but if you liked
my review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck with knives